mais comment ils vont la nouveaux décors
nouveaux styles c'est un match décor on
dirait que fut devenu surfer alors que
pas du tout je suis encore au niveau de
la brasse avec leur confinement je me
suis un peu remis à lire des livres
ouais les livres vous savez ce truc
rectangulaire là avec des pages dedans
et des mots écrits ce truc qui rend voie
de disparition parce que sur le
gouvernement va les livres c'est un
produit qui serait donnée essentielle
moi j'ai tendance à monter sur mes
grands chefs de abba cissé c'est
vraiment essentiel sais pas si c'est
parce qu'il ya de plus en plus d'écrans
qui nous entoure et tous et moi j'arrive
plus vraiment à lire à chaque fois que
je commence un livre c'est toujours la
même chose je suis super excitée de
commencer je le poste sur install alors
que je n'ai même pas ouvert je commence
je me sens hyper intelligent et au bout
de cinq minutes du coup lendemain je
sais plus où j'en suis alors je me
retape de chapitres pour rien toutes les
trois minutes je vérifie où j'en suis a
quand même page 8 quand je m'arrête ces
jeux corde le coin de la hache mais vu
que je m'arrête pour le temps par mon
livre ressemble à un origami
au bout d'un moment mes yeux lise et non
servir force complètement à autre chose
est ce que j'ai donné à manger aux chats
aujourd'hui et si vous repeignez le
salon
et voilà terminé c'est cool sa barque
comme sait pas par contre il faut
repeindre le savons bon voila moi je
suis comme ça il ya des tonnes de gens
qui sont super à l'aise avec la lecture
qui ont aucun problème qui voit même pas
de quoi je parle
comme ces gens qui lisent un livre
entier en deux jours qui es tu de quelle
planète viens tu d'ailleurs il ya plein
d'autres styles de lecteurs énervant
celui qui se tape une barre tout seul en
lisant son livre mon livre est mon
meilleur ami
c'est mon refuge dans la vie personne ne
m'aime celui qui lit mais avoir autant
dire en écoute à des voix qui sortaient
de ma celle pour voir le dit il mâcher
le match et le celui qui lie carrément
ton livre celui qui lie absolument
partout tout le temps
ou encore celui qui lèche son doigt
avant de tourner la page [ __ ] tiens je
le prête ou d'ailleurs en parlant de
prêter les budgets c'est dans la vie
quand tu prête un truc à quelqu'un
normalement éclairant mais pour les
livres on dirait qu'il existe une règle
spéciale où les gens pensent qu'ils ont
le droit d'une pâte les rendre et après
tu vas chez eux et comme par hasard
tiens c'est marrant dans ce livre
vaillamment livre un nom sur la scène a
annoncé le mien je me rappelle très bien
je lui ai prêté il ya des années ce
livre je voulais même pas terminé mecque
pour maintenant je m'en fous un peu mais
voilà sur le principe ça m'énerve donc
pour la peine je t'en prendre quelques
livres je comprends mais pourquoi les
gens utilisent des liseuses au moins
avec les liseuses tu prête pas trop
livre quoi comme un bon cru en moi j'ai
pas de liseuses toi je m'en fous mais je
comprends pas ces gens qui sont anti
liseuse ans c'est qu'ils mènent
carrément un combat contre les liseuses
et sortent toujours le même discours
en fait mon livre j'ai besoin de toucher
le sentir
le pain est page après page
de retrouver un petit peu de sable qui
provient de la plage parfois de mettre
mon livre j'ai tourné dans fusion avec
lui fait je crois même qu que j'ai envie
que le quelle belle paire de couilles
alors selon les sondages on lit de moins
en moins de livres c'est dommage les
gens ont la flemme de lire et pas que
les livres sur les articles de presse
des fois c'est écrite en lecture deux
minutes trois minutes comme si les gens
avaient besoin de toutes tailles mais
bon après cette option elle pourrait
être assez cool hein sur des gros relou
j'arrive dans aujourd'hui nos cerveaux
sont tellement connecter à dix mille
trucs en même temps on est tellement
sollicité que pour vraiment l'air
sérieusement faire une grosse coupure
moi je comprends qu'à l'époque les gens
lisaient plus vous avez que ça les gars
ce soir soirée lecture ou rien est
d'accord donc tout le monde dit que tout
le monde sur son livre même pionce par
super soirée j'exagère un peu mais jean
paul sartre s'il était né à notre époque
ça se trouve peut-être pas qui fait la
littérature
il aurait peut-être pris un un autre
chemin et jean paul sartre remporté le
tournoi short nike avec 48 qu'il se bat
actuellement pour les gens comme moi qui
ont un peu la flemme
j'ai découvert et essayer et livres
audio en fait tu es plus de quelqu'un
qui te lit le livre
ouais j'ai lu germinal rue on me l'a
même quoi qu'elle clame là lui échappe
raconteront mois le dernier livre ou
malussé petit ours brun
donc en plus la voix de la personne qui
te lit le livre et les hyper importante
système pas sa voix
tu arrives pas écouté
[Musique]
l'histoire se déroule d'un levier new
york fait quoi comme ça je suis vidé o
cha qui toi qu'est personnes dans le
monde du livre audio j'ai un nom tu vas
me bats les couilles je vais faire
rouler plus le pour les yaourts c ou
freinent les livres audio scellé ce
livre que tu peux lire en faisant autre
chose tu fais quand des devoirs la tabac
j'écoute a mené un tour livres audio là
adacore à temps pour moi je suce moi je
vais je faire de toi abonnés et en plus
c'est une croix son compte
après il ya livres et livre un des fois
tu vas chez leclerc
tu vois les livres car en tête de
gondole tu dis si je lis ça je perds des
neurones j'ai essayé aussi de lire des
mangas mais personne n'avait prévenu
qu'il fallait le lire dans l'autre sens
du coup au bout de quelques pages
j'étais genre à temps mais le mec qui
meurt et après il revit tu comprends
rien du tout là et vous alors qu'elle
livre me conseilleriez vous à paramétrer
la allez ciao ciao ciao ciao
[Musique]